I think the question of failure
has to do with what our goals are.
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here today.
I want to talk about why people
fail at language learning.
Now, if you enjoy these videos,
please subscribe, click on
the bell for notifications.
So what do I mean by that?
What do I mean when I say that
people fail at language learning?
Well, if I look at the example in
Canada, which is the situation I know
the best, just about every English
speaking Canadian has French at school.
Depending on the province it might be six
years, eight years, 10 years of French.
Very few of those kids graduate from
high school, able to speak French.
Very few.
I gather from what I hear in
other countries, English-speaking
countries, that the same is true.
Now, there are always some who ended
up speaking very well and, you know, go
off to the country where the language
is spoken, but they are a very small
minority, the vast majority fail.
Now, I don't know what the situation is
in other countries, but I lived in Japan.
Everyone has English at school.
The vast majority don't
understand English.
Uh, I traveled in Spain.
It's the same.
Now there's always a small number
of people who speak english
or other languages well, but
the majority of people don't.
I suspect that the vast majority of
people who study languages, in fact,
don't end up speaking the language.
So are they failures?
Again, it all depends on
how you define failure.
So if I get back to the example of
English-speaking kids in Canada, most of
those kids passed their French at school.
They didn't fail.
They got seven out of 10, eight
out of 10, nine out of 10, whatever
most of them passed, they had to
pass to get out of high school.
So they didn't fail in that sense,
but they failed in the sense that they
didn't learn to speak the language.
Um, right now I've been at my Arabic
for three years and my Persian
for two, I can't say that I speak
either language particularly well.
I really struggle now I,
my Farsi is now better.
I've had the opportunity to use
it a bit here and there around,
uh, Vancouver, North Vancouver,
especially West Vancouver.
Arabic, uh, I'm now exploring
Egypt in Arabic with Mohammed, my
tutor, and I do struggle in our
conversations, there is no question.
But am I failing in the language?
So here again, I'm not, I
don't think I'm failing because
I'm enjoying what I'm doing.
I understand more and more.
So I think the question of failure
has to do with what our goals are,
goals that we set for ourselves or
goals that other people set for us.
Now, I suspect that in our English
language school system in Canada
most of those students have only one
goal and that's to pass the test.
They're not particularly
interested in speaking French.
So, uh, they succeeded
based on their goal.
They didn't succeed based on a goal
that sort of someone else expects of
them, and that is the ability to speak.
Maybe in our school system,
we should put the emphasis on
comprehension and not on speaking.
Speaking implies speaking correctly.
So once you attempt to speak or to write
you produce the language so that the
teacher can correct you, give you marks,
or even when you're listening, the teacher
is going to test you on your listening
comprehension, setting you up for failure.
Setting you up for, you know,
things that you can't do.
If we simply said we're going to expose
kids in school to a lot of content, uh,
hopefully content they're interested
in, or, you know, I sometimes think
if, if, um, kids in the Canadian, you
know, English language, school system
had nothing, but the 60 mini stories
and every year they only did the mini
stories, at least at the end of it all,
they would understand the mini stories.
You would think after 5, 6, 8 years.
Right now, I'm not sure they would
understand the mini stories unless
they've been in the French immersion.
So actually they're achieving
very, very little in their French.
Despite all kinds of instruction
on subjunctive and the tenses and
things like that, which they try to
kind of hang onto in order to pass
their tests and then quickly forget.
So I think part of the failure
in our school system is this
emphasis on producing the
language and using it correctly.
In fact, the vast majority of
English speaking people, kids in
Canada, have no need to speak French.
They have no one to speak French with.
So it's an unrealistic expectation.
Maybe the same is true in Japan.
The vast majority of Japanese people
have no one to speak English to.
They have no real need to speak English,
except for that one time when maybe,
maybe they'll travel to Europe or to,
you know, somewhere where else where
they'll need English to communicate.
But then it's too late because
they've spent all that time,
you know, trying to learn how to
speak and they still can't speak.
Again, if the emphasis had been
on comprehension, if at least
to have a very high level of
comprehension, the speaking will come.
I'm absolutely convinced, but without that
solid base in comprehension, the speaking,
you know, they might kind of achieve an
ability to say a few things for the test
or to produce a few things for the test.
But after that it's gone because
they don't understand fundamentally
don't understand the language.
So I think a big part of failure
is this emphasis on speaking and
producing the language, which is
unrealistic because realistically to
speak well, you have to speak a lot.
The Majority of people who are learning
a language in an environment where they
don't have the opportunity to speak a lot,
they're not going to end up speaking well.
So it's far more useful in my opinion,
to emphasize comprehension and let them
graduate from very simple, repetitive
material to movies, things of interest to
them where all the time, the emphasis on
comprehension, not comprehension that we
test people on just comprehension because
they're listening to things initially
that are repetitious, but then eventually
things that are of interest to them
that will reduce the degree of failure.
Learners won't be measuring
themselves against something that
is an unrealistic expectation, the
ability to speak the language well,
they will be measuring themselves the
way I do with my Arabic and Persian.
You know, am I still doing it?
Am I enjoying it?
Is it, does it correspond to
what I am interested in doing?
And as long as all of those things
are true, even if I can't speak
well, I'm meeting my objectives.
So I'm not, uh, failing in the
language, but if the expectation
is that after six months I should
speak the language and then I can't,
then I feel as if I have failed.
So I think where I'm coming from on this
is that we need to change the objectives
of language instruction, and put a
far greater emphasis on comprehension,
which means more listening and reading.
Letting people enjoy whatever
they're able to do in the language.
There's far less testing, far less,
you know, marking people down.
And on that basis, I think people will
feel better about their language learning.
And as a result, they will
learn better and we'll have less
failure in language learning.
I look forward to your comments.
Thank you for listening.
Bye for now.